foreign
to talk a little bit about my obsession
with AI yeah let's do it because it's
changed a lot so let me just put it to
you this way
you know how I always track new
like yes I pride myself in always being
someone to want to play with whatever is
kind of halfway working slash breaking
if it means that you know five years
from now I was able to spot something
early on and and you know hopefully
identify a trend before it really took
off so I would say that
gbt when it came out the chat gbt the
first few versions were just were just
fun for me it was kind of like oh I'm
having a conversation with AI wow it's
it's actually producing a real result
when I'm like typing to it it can help
me rephrase or rewrite a paragraph or
you know it can summarize some bullet
points like there's it was doing a lot
of little small meaningless more or less
tasks but quite well and then 4.0 came
out yeah so when 4.0 came out my
consumption of and usage of chat GPT
went from about you know let's call it
30 minutes a week to probably about five
hours a week now no kidding so I use it
a lot what are you using it for now I'm
using it to code so it can it can code
for me now so you know my background
here like I studied computer science but
I dropped out and part of the reason I I
don't know how much I mentioned this
publicly but part of the reason I
dropped out was that
I could look and understand code a lot
faster than I can write it yeah and so
you know it's still to this day I can I
can read code just fine I mean this
granted sometimes there's some syntax I
would have to look up or figure out but
like more or less I'm there the issue
was that if I'm thinking through a
problem it would take me you know three
to four times as long as anyone else to
like figure out the same problem and it
just I just didn't have the brain for it
yeah GPT I can come in and as I start to
have little hiccups or I want to think
through a problem I can just ask it to
figure it out for me and it writes code
that is like 99 like ready to go give
you an example of Give an example let's
say you are your WordPress user right
that's what your blog's powered on and
you're like I want to write a new
WordPress plugin and I want it to do
this with my audience segment it like
this
do this only when someone is coming from
this country and make it appear like
this and you know you could change
anything you want you just describe it
in a couple paragraphs and say go it
literally will print out all the code
for you you copy and paste it and save
it as a script and you're good to go and
it works it's insane so what does that
mean for say five years from now well a
couple things practically speaking right
now my engineering team I had one of my
developers tell me hey I had this like
what they would call a a kind of
laborious kind of task of like just
something you don't want to code you're
like ah God I gotta Resort this data in
a certain way and like yeah this is
going to take me 45 minutes it was done
in five right and it's like using chat
GPS yes and so like all of those little
meaningless coding tasks they're just
gone right like that's it's already it's
done it's done yeah and so I've been
using it to create art and I can tell it
to go and write
p5.js scripts for me which is what art
blocks is based on for all the nfts so
art meaning you're using code to
generate generative art exactly and so I
can describe it visually and it comes
back with something that's amazing
that's cool I'll show you some examples
after the podcast I'd love to see it and
it's crazy addicting because you start
getting into it and you're like oh what
if you take it in this direction in this
direction so you're only limited you're
limited no longer by your skill but your
own internal creativity of your of your
brain and your ability to prompt well
yes yes but you can even help it right
I'll give an example this is about to
get super meta yeah exactly you can tell
it I'm having a hard time writing a
prompt how might I be more efficient and
it'll give you 10 ways to rewrite the
prompt see and it's so it just it's
helping itself it's so nuts yeah and so
once you realize that it's so much more
than just rewriting a paragraph where
you are helping put together an essay
but it can actually create real software
for you dude it's it's just
I realize now that what's going to
happen is that you know Mark Andreessen
was very famous very famous venture
capitalist maybe a decade ago of saying
software is eating the world right and
so it was this idea that we had all of
these old systems that were largely you
know pen and paper based or weren't
connected or weren't efficient and
software would come in and be connected
be put the data we've put in the cloud
and we would have you know this new type
of of in-cloud infrastructure right that
would power everything and be connected
like it never was before all that is is
is still continuing to happen but this
next generation is what I believe his AI
is going to eat the software so if
if software ate the world AI is going to
eat the software meaning that AI is
going to come in and reimagine every
single tool that we use so every single
productivity tool that we use it will be
a part of almost every application that
we use in in really meaningful ways like
I've seen it it sort data and create you
know so I don't know about you but when
I use Excel the hardest thing for me to
always wrap my head around and figure
out where pivot tables do you ever get
good at pivot tables no I've never got
good at Excel period oh my God pivot
tables were one of those things where it
was just like it was it was a they're a
nightmare to I use notebooks and then I
lose my notebooks so anyway you don't
have to learn it any longer you just
tell it what you want how you want the
data slice and dice and it just like it
not not when I what I don't mean is the
output from chat gbt but I mean it will
be working in Excel or in Google Sheets
and just automatically rewrite the
tables for you that's why and so it's
you're just going to give it a little
prompt and that's it and I'm telling you
this this is coming a lot faster than I
had thought so two years ago it was very
linear to me I was like ah month over
month like oh yeah chat gbt3 is out now
now 3.5 and I see a little bit of an
upgrade when four hit oh my God
vertical it's gone vertical it's
exponential now and so dude the next
couple years are going to be insane